[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire en 2019 avec un peu moins de
2 milliards de déficit de la sécurité
sociale était à peu près en équilibre
sachant que les recettes nettes
s'élevaient à un peu plus de 400
milliards mais cette année on s'attend
un trou de plus de 38 milliards un
niveau extrêmement élevé proche de celui
de 2020 dû en particulier à la pandémie
de covin 19 alors il y avait le projet
de grande sécu qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre l'idée tant que la
quasi-totalité des remboursements soient
prises en charge par l'assurance maladie
ou détriment des mutuelles mais le
ministre de la santé olivier vers ans
aurait abandonné le projet d'après le
point trop compliqué à mettre en place
et au même moment en annonce que les
tarifs des complémentaires santé
pourrait fortement augmenter en 2022 ce
qui étonne le ministère car les
mutuelles aurait économisé plus de 2
milliards pendant la pandémie
l'intégralité des soins liés au virus
n'ayant été remboursés par la sécu alors
comment réformer un système de soins qui
coûte de plus en plus cher et cela sans
exclure les plus précaires et comment
finir avec ce satané trou de la sécu
dont on nous rebat les oreilles depuis
toujours pendez battre nous avons invité
frédéric bizarre économiste de la santé
vous enseignez à sciences po université
dauphine et le spl le s&p business
school la plus ancienne école de
commerce du monde elle a été fondée en
1819 à l'époque on ne parlait pas encore
de business school président et
fondateur de l'institut de santé de
l'institut sentez vous êtes l'auteur de
l'autonomie solidaire en santé paru en
octobre chez michalon la france at-elle
encore les moyens de son système de
santé frédéric bizarre ça choque lieu on
commence à en voir les limites oui mais
c'est pas faux ce n'est pas uniquement
une question de moyens la france dépense
après 11,3 pour cent de son pib de la
création de sa richesse nationale à peu
près comme l'allemagne la question c'est
véritablement la nature de ces dépenses
à qualité de ses dépenses plus que le
niveau de ses dépenses on a un système
qui reste très centré sur le curatif
c'est à dire que la stratégie est à peu
près la même qui à 50 ans c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'accès aux soins qu'on attend
que les gens soient malades et on les
soigne et assez remarquablement la
plupart du temps notamment quand ils ont
des pathologies graves et on les soigne
plus tôt beaucoup à l'hôpital que en
ambulatoire donc en fait on fait tout ce
qu'il ya de plus cher et on n'a pas
basculé vers un modèle qui permet de
maîtriser la dépense à partir du
maintien en bonne santé d'accord donc à
partir d'un investissement plutôt que
simplement les soins donc ses parts nous
aurons les moyens de conserver un
système de santé de haut niveau si on
change de stratégie on évolue vers un
accès à la santé globale on permet aux
gens de vivre en bonne santé plus
longtemps et ces essais par c'est un
petit peu comme la consommation
d'énergie c'est la meilleure économie
c'est c'est celle que ce sont les
dépenses qu'on ne qu'on ne fait pas et
bien la meilleure économie des soins
c'est pas le rabotage que l'on fait
depuis dix ans en essayant d'économiser
en reportant l'entraidé des médicaments
innovants en faisant des des réductions
de dépenses à l'hôpital qui sont des
réductions qui qui qui agissent sur la
qualité de l'environnement et on le voit
aujourd'hui avec une perte
d'attractivité c'est évidemment en
maintenant les gens en bonne santé plus
longtemps on sait qu'en faisant basculer
de l'aval c'est-à-dire de quand les gens
sont malades à l'amont quand les gens
sont bien portants parce qu'on a tous le
gradient social peut-être que les gens
qui sont là haut sont plutôt en bonne
santé parce qu'ils ont la chance d'avoir
un niveau socio éducatif assez haut mais
si vous regardez sur l'ensemble de la
population vous avez des inégalités
sociales de santé qui sont beaucoup plus
importants en france qu' en moyenne dans
l'union européenne parce qu'on n'agit
pas en amont là où sont les bonnes
économies ça veut pas dire que c'est
gratuit 1 le maintien en bonne santé
c'est de l'investissement dans le
capital humain
jean-jacques vers celle de président de
l'habituel de france unies et de l'union
de réassurance et de substitution social
président fondateur et administrateur de
l'union nationale elle ternit
alternative mutualiste doit être
président historique
à votre avis la france a les moyens de
conserver son système de soins oui je
pense qu'elle a largement les moyens de
le conserver voire même de l'améliorer
donc
je partage ce que vous disiez il ya déjà
tout ce que l'on pourrait faire en
prévention en amont qui est très peu
réalisé en tout cas au niveau de la
sécurité sociale quelquefois les budgets
sont pas utilisés
donc sur la prévention c'est déjà en
amant une manière de maintenir la
population en meilleure santé après il
ya en france on a un gros problème quand
même c'est l'accès aux soins
est c'est vrai que selon il faut parler
aussi des déserts médicaux parce qu'il
ya une partie de la population
qui peine enfin bon on a pas mal de
collègues mutualiste dans les régions
centre où on peine à trouver des
professionnels de santé
après il ya quand même un gros souci si
on voudrait une sécurité sociale
universelle c'est quand même le
traitement du secteur 2 parce que c'est
quoi le secteur de le secteur 2 c les
spécialistes qui font du dépassement 1
je crois que c'est raymond barre qui
avait autorisé sa
du temps où il était premier ministre et
ça ça nuit quand même à halak s'est en
tout cas des spécialistes puisque on
peut quand même trouvé des généralistes
en secteur 1 bien que la démographie
médicale
plus les nouvelles habitudes des jeunes
médecins font que
ils font plus 70 heures comme ça se
faisait il ya 10 15 ans
et donc il ya quand même le l'accès aux
soins qui est largement pénalisés et
notamment tout à l'heure on parlait avec
votre assistante du des problèmes
dentaires et
là ya un véritable souci avec toute
l'offre libérale qui ne permet pas
forcément aux gens d'accéder aux soins
dans de bonnes conditions
jean baptiste nos épreuves sur
d'économie politique à la sorbonne
rédacteur en chef de la revue conflit
vous êtes l'auteur avec victor fouquet
de la révolte fiscale qui a reçu le prix
turgot l'année dernière il est paru chez
calmann lévy on a encore les moyens de
notre système de soins d'après vous
c'est pas tellement une question de
moyens enfin je veux pas répéter ce qui
a été dit non je partage pleinement le
constat ce qui me fait un peu plus
gênant pour dans la sécurité sociale
s'il le fait c'est à ce thème qui n'est
pas du tout transparent et qui est
incompréhensible pour une grande partie
de la population fia qu'il ya une sorte
de mythe de la sécu sur ses origines de
création qui sont souvent erronées et
sur le fait qu'elle apporte à mettre à
la population ce qui n'est pas
complètement faux mais allez dire que
c'est pas né avec le conseil de la rive
notamment ses a commencé avec carnaval
janvier 1928 1930 à ça près une
quinzaine d'années pour ce faire
d'ailleurs avec
le gouvernement du maréchal pétain en
1940 rhône est bonne à pierre laroque
été inventé par bismarck en prison voilà
c'est ça dont il a fallu une quinzaine
d'années il a fallu quatre régimes
politiques différents donc c'est un
système qui est assez trans partisan
c'est vraiment le l'émanation de la
quantité de l'état qui fait qu
indépendamment des guerres et des
conflits le système se met en place et
abouti et mais on est un système
aujourd'hui la plupart des gens ne
savent pas comment ça fonctionne ne sait
pas non plus combien ils payent tous les
mois dans une fiche de paye et
difficilement lisible pour un salarié et
donc dès qu'on aborde le côté social
comme on ne sait pas vraiment combien on
paye combien on est remboursé comment ça
fonctionne on ne peut pas y avoir de
débat possible ni d' analyse rationnelle
possible or c'est un enjeu démocratique
fondamental et il faudra arriver au
moins à simplifier le fonctionnement est
l'explication du fonctionnement pour
qu'on n'ait pas besoin d'avoir fait des
très hautes études pour savoir
exactement combien on paye et combien on
est remboursé nicolas da silva
économiste enseigné à l'université paris
xiii ou est l'un des des trois auteurs
d'économie de la santé le livre de
référence chez armand colin alors même
question est ce qu'on a encore les
moyens de notre système de soins alors
oui on a les moyens notre système de
soins et moi je tendrai la question
autrement c est ce que notre système de
soins a encore les moyens de l'austérité
et des crises du capitalisme
voilà un petit peu un petit peu l'enjeu
est la première chose à faire peut-être
ces deux des maths dédramatiser l'enjeu
l'enjeu du trou de la sécu l'enjeu du
déficit de la sécu parce que toutes ces
questions en fait l anesthésie le débat
parce que voilà les mots les chiffres
sont en ordre de bataille vous rendez
bien compte vous rendez bien compte il
ya des déficits avec des chiffres qu'on
est même pas capable de ce2 de se
matérialiser et évidemment tout de suite
on se dit ah bah il faut bien il faut
bien pour la sauver pratique et la
saignée non il faut dédramatiser il faut
se dire que dès le début la sécurité
sociale est contestée sur sur sa
capacité à être à l'équilibré que on
place le début en 1945 ou bien avant les
gouvernements vous avez parlé la
sécurité sociale et l'organisation
collective de la santé en france a
toujours été critiquée sur différents
modes pour dire que ça coûtait trop cher
que ça inciter à la feignantise à
inciter à la consommation non justifiée
de soins tout ça on en fait on n'est pas
du tout capable de le démontrer et au
contraire comme vous l'avez dit l'un au
grand problème aujourd'hui c'est le
problème de l'accès aux soins avec
beaucoup de gens qu'ils renoncent à
accéder à des soins la pandémie a montré
avec éclat que notre problème ce n'était
pas un problème d'argent quand il a
fallu mettre l'argent pour assurer un
accès aux soins à tous pour enfin donner
des moyens aux hôpitaux et pas encore
suffisamment mais on a pu le faire et
toutes ces questions qui avait
anesthésié le débat public pendant des
années la dette le déficit et cetera et
cetera elles se sont cul posé
momentanément aujourd'hui elle se repose
pourquoi non pas parce qu'elles sont
devenues réelles d'un point de vue
monétaire budgétaire mais elle se repose
parce qu'il ya un agenda politique qui
est de remettre en cause la sécurité
sociale alors qu'au contraire il
faudrait l'étendre notamment avec le
projet de grande section alors justement
le trou de la sécu dont on nous parle
depuis toujours
vous vous dites il existe ou n'existe
pas alors le trou de la sécu c'est un
concept rhétorique pour comme je le
disais anesthésier le débat à partir du
moment où on dit trou de la sécu on se
dit ah il va falloir faire des réformes
est systématiquement on se dit des
réformes pour réduire les dépenses alors
que lorsqu'on a une analyse comptable on
peut adopter un déjà un vocabulaire un
petit peu différent et essayer de
déterminer l'origine de ce déficit qui a
un déficit de la sécurité sociale c'est
vrai mais la question c'est d'où il
vient et en fait il vient de la
politique de l'état qui constamment ces
dernières décennies a déshabillé la
sécurité sociale en pratiquant des
politiques qui visé à réduire les
cotisations sociales qui était déco
politique pour l'emploi on voit bien que
ça n'a pas marché
donc la sécurité sociale elle est en
déficit non seulement à cause des
politiques de l'état mais elle est aussi
en déficit comme je le disais tout à
l'heure à cause des crises du
capitalisme quels sont les grands
moments de grand déficit de la sécurité
sociale à la fois c'était en 2009 entre
2008 et 2009 le trou de la sécu comme on
l'appelle double pourquoi parce qu'entre
temps il ya le capitalisme eric 1 est le
nôtre qui se sont
partiellement effondrés
et en fait aujourd'hui aussi la plus
grande raison pour laquelle il ya un
déficit de la sécurité sociale c'est
l'écroulement
des recettes et cet écoulement des
recettes c'est peut-être ce dont il faut
parler de façon plus est d'accord
je vois tu es mauvais week roulement des
recettes il ya pour reprenez un salaire
médian par exemple donc le lien qui va
gagner à peu près mille 700 euros brut
il va entre cotisations salariales et
patronales il paye à peu près 1000 70
euros notre la branche retraite et la
branche santé donc ça fait mille plus de
1000 euros payer tous les mois cotisés
tous les mois pour la sécu branche
retraite ou santé ce qui est un chiffre
important et donc on a cette difficulté
à matérialiser le coût réel c'est
d'ailleurs un des problèmes aussi du
fait qu'on ait remboursés
automatiquement s'il ya qu'on ne sait
plus combien va coûter une cotisation
chez le médecin combien coûte des
médicaments donc on est dans une logique
de déresponsabilisation ce qui fait que
le débat est rendue difficile déjà si on
était remboursé a posteriori on saurait
exactement combien on a payé et donc on
se rendrait compte aussi du coût d'un
médicament et elle vous répondez pas sur
le trou lui même le trou il existe ou
n'existe pas à bas le trouviez de joie
20 mobile projetée 20 milliards d'euros
dans le budget l'ascl sociale voté
l'assemblée nationale donc plus plus
aucune 38 est un peu plus voilà c'est
fait rentrer dedans donc c'était un
déficit qui a été important mais ça
dépend ce qu'on y met à l'intérieur
parce qu'il ya différentes branches donc
selon les branches qu'on y met le trou
peut varier il ya la question aussi de
la fraude autour des fausses cartes
vitales autour des abus de médicaments
et puis un des problèmes du domaine de
la santé c'est la distinction entre ceux
qui travaillent effectivement dans la
santé infirmiers médecins et tout
l'appareil administratif qui est plus
important en france qu en allemagne et
qui a un coût alors que ce n'est pas
directement dévolu à la santé et bizarre
alors c'est de reprendre de trois points
quand même qui n'équipe qui à mon avis
nécessite un petit peu de l'explication
d'abord pourquoi notre système de soins
est par terre aujourd'hui ça a été ça a
été objectivement un des meilleurs au
20e siècle justement dans l'accès aux
soins la première génération des
systèmes de santé qu'on a vu partout
dans les pays développés c'était des
systèmes qui avait justement à vocation
à donner un accès aux soins c'est-à-dire
à médicaliser l'ensemble des territoires
puisque c'est la première étape quand on
travaille des pays émergents on essaye
que tout le monde est un accès aux soins
avant de se ruer se préoccuper plus
davantage de questions de maintien en
bonne santé de faire en sorte que les
gens vivent bonne santé plus longtemps
ça on l'a fait de façon remarquable
c'est à dire que et je pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui on puisse dire que le
premier problème en france c'est l'accès
aux soins il ya assez peu d'injustice en
matière d'accès aux soins en france même
si la situation se dégrade vous avez pré
plus de six millions de personnes qui
ont des difficultés à aller voir un
médecin généraliste donc ça devient un
problème mais la faille du système de
soins français il est dans sa
constitution originale qui est de
privilégier uniquement cet accès aux
soins pourquoi c'est un problème parce
que vous avez trois transition et c'est
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que c'est
l'environnement qui a ravi qui a
radicalement changé et pas notre système
qui est tout d'un coup devenu
complètement désuet mais il est plus
adapté à l'environnement vous avez la
première transition qui la transition
démographique le fait que vous ayez un
basculement où vous avez plus de gens
qui ont plus de 60 ans par rapport à des
gens qui ont moins de 20 ans pose un
problème comme ça a été très bien dit d'
équilibre dans les recettes puisque vous
avez des recettes qui sont basés sur
principalement les revenus des actifs à
partir quand vous avez un ratio actif
sur inactifs qui baissent forcément vous
avez dans l'assiette de financement mais
ça pose aussi un problème du fait que
comme vous avez une corrélation
c'est-à-dire un lien entre le fait que
vous soyez âge et le fait que vous ayez
potentiellement des maladies et que
comme on vous a pas tellement bien
éduqué dans se maintient en bonne santé
dans cette éducation à la santé là vous
avez et on l'a vu avec le co vide parce
qu'on a vu que c'était en fait les états
unis la france un certain nombre de pays
qui avaient une vulnérabilité très forte
des états unis avec leurs taux d'obésité
et la france avec le nombre de personnes
qui avaient des affections de longue
durée or ce sont ces personnes là qui
sont en situation fragile et si vous
avez en effet aujourd'hui un problème de
financement de cet accès aux soins c'est
dur pourrait on va en dire deux mots
probablement c'est dû à à l'ineptie de
ce système de complémentaire santé que
vous avez un deuxième étage qui est
absolument illisible comme ça a été dit
c'est à dire que les français ne ne
savent pas qui finance quoi comme vous
avez un deuxième étage quasiment
généralisé vous avez essayé pas la faute
des assureurs c'est que c'est le système
qui a tant qui est en cause vous avez
des surcoûts administratif absolument
colossaux une quinzaine de milliards ce
compte vous aller à la pharmacie et que
vous en sortez vous vous sortez votre
carte vitale et plus votre carte bleue
mais en fait ce qui fait que vous ne
sortez plus votre carte bleue c'est que
96% des français ont une couverture
complémentaire qui va prendre à sa
charge mais d'aider des dépenses qui
n'ont au qui ne devrait pas être prise
en charge par une assurance parce que ce
sont de petites dépenses quand vous
allez à la pharmacie donc vous avez
aujourd'hui apprennent de financement
d'accès aux soins parce que vous avez
une assurance maladie donc public qui
est concentré pour les deux tiers de ses
dépenses sur 12 millions de français qui
ont des affections de longue durée et
donc vous avez 54 millions de français
qui se partagent si vous voulez un tiers
de ces dépenses d'assurance maladie et
le phénomène ne va aller où que de façon
croissante puisqu'on s'attend à en 2025
avoir à peu près près de 80% des
dépenses d'assurance-maladie concentré
sur ce qu'on appelle le gros risque les
affections de longue durée que fait-on
du reste là en effet on a des trous dans
la raquette qui fait que les français
ont qui à qui on a quand même donné le
réflexe de faire payer les dépenses de
soins par un assureur savait qu'en
france on se targue à peu près tous les
jours surtout les assureurs privés de
dire mais vous rendez compte que grâce à
nous vous avez que 7% de restes à charge
contre 20% sur la moyenne des pays
développés mais on cumule le fait
d'avoir le reste à charge globale le
plus faible au monde et d'avoir des
renoncements soyez s'est dit par un
assureur s'est dit par des économies
slip dans un problème d'accès aux soins
et pourtant on est le pays avec la
couverture assurancielle mais de très
loin la plus large donc il ya bien un
problème dans l'organisation de cette
assurance est donc pour revenir sur la
grande sécu le gouvernement a raison de
mettre sur la table de se dire il faut
qu'on mette sur la table cette
architecture de financement mais si
derrière la grande sait qu on y met
l'étatisation du système c'est-à-dire
qu'on transfère on va vers un modèle à
l'anglais ou si on y met la suppression
totale des mutuelles on parle dans le
vide on parle dans sur un système
totalement illusoire il faut avoir un
peu les principes de réalité c'est que
vous avez des mutuelles qui sont là qui
peuvent avoir un rôle tout cas pour les
vrais mutuelle qui peuvent avoir un rôle
en matière d'économie sociale et
solidaire absolument déterminant
notamment dans le maintien en bonne
santé dans la dépendance et dans le
financement d'une partie des soins mais
il faut qu'il ya un payeur unique par
prestations de santé faut arrêter ce
système à deux étages qui n'existe qu'en
france chaque version wii alors une
liste n'est en fait on fait partie des
mutuelles qui ont toujours soutenu la
sécurité sociale dès son origine parce
que dans le mouvement mutualiste je bats
il ya deux gérés ya deux grandes
familles mutualiste et donc on fait
partie
des mutuelles issus des mutuelles de
travailleurs qui ont dès l'origine
soutenu la sécurité sociale et je dirais
que c'est par défaut qu'aujourd'hui on
fait du complémentaire parce que je
dirige président de savoie deux
structures une structure complémentaire
et des centres de santé et on a quand
même 250 personnes dans les centres de
santé où on fait de la prévention est de
l'accès aux soins donc dans la mutualité
il ya quand même
il ya quand même différentes tendances
et donc que nous on est pour une
sécurité sociale universelle et qui
prennent en charge le j'irai
la totalité des dépenses mais pour cela
ça peut se faire
que dans un système où quelque part ont
contraint les remboursements c'est à
dire qu'on abandonne enfin qu'on
supprime le secteur 2 qu'on limite
toutes les dépenses hospitalières avec
la chambre particulière le forfait
hospitalier tout ça faut que ça soit
pris en charge et de manière cohérente
après moi je crois pas du tout à la
grande sécurité sociale pour deux
raisons c'est parce que vous parliez à
juste titre des ald et enfin je crois et
après il ya un autre donc les ldc les
gens qui ont des maladies chroniques et
les gens qui ont des maladies chroniques
ne peuvent pas intéressé les assureurs
personnellement j'ai un diabète ça doit
coûter 300 euros par mois je veux dire
je vais pas trouver un assureur si je
vis dans un pays comme les etats unis et
si je travaille pas qui valut à vouloir
m'accepter et puis après vous avez une
deuxième catégorie de population qui a
qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de moyens
financiers pour se payer une mutuelle
est là on a mis en place un système qui
s'appelle la c2 s ur les gens ont lors
du duel de prise en charge notamment par
des taxes qui sont vous payé par
l'ensemble des complémentaires santé
et en fait on laisse dans le marché
tout le secteur dans l'entreprise et
tous les bien portants et donc ça c'est
une tendance profonde et je vois mal
parce que ça c'est vraiment la politique
libérale dans son absolue
j'irai étendue et je vois mal un
gouvernement parce que cela ce que ce
dont je vous parle ça s'est mis en place
il ya 20 ou 30 ans petit à petit et je
vois mal un gouvernement qui est plutôt
libérale mettre un coup de frein par
rapport à tout ce qui s'est fait pour
revenir en arrière et prôné une sécurité
sociale universelle en tout cas une
grande sécurité sociale comme ils le
disent parce que ça aura des consignes a
pas des contours très flous quand vous
parlez de dépendances
j'ai dirigé une mutuelle de prévoyance
et la dépendance à mon avis ça doit être
quelque chose qui doit être assuré par
la sécurité sociale parce que c'est
réclament des moyens financiers autres
que pour le pour le petit risque et
jamais à part si on s'appelle score avec
ça gers est un système si on le laisse
dans le système assurantiel il y aura de
la sélection médicale comme on le fait
quand il est à titre individuel et donc
ça peut être vraiment c'est quelque
chose qui doit être portée absolument
par la sécurité sociale et la prévention
pour vous doit être portée par qui elle
peut être portée par la sécurité sociale
les mutuelles
parce que ce rôle enfin ce rôle social
qui a été jouée par les mutuelles qu'il
l'ait encore mais de façon marginale
compléter de façon assez remarquer mme
un système assez libérale est compris
dans la délivrance des services en ville
où vous aviez un système d'exercice
libéral qui avait besoin d'un complément
social avec les centres de santé souvent
portés par les mutuelles donc le système
a bien fonctionné avec ses deux
compléments là avant que ça se dérègle
notamment vous parlez du secteur 2 qui
derrière le secteur de la liberté des
tarifs mais pourquoi il ya eu un secteur
2 et pourquoi y compris personne n'est
revenu dessus parce que justement vous
aviez 7 il faut comprendre parce que les
appuyer une raison et c'est pour ça que
sa demande de changer le système parce
qu'en fait vous avez une sécurité
sociale qui s'est concentré de plus en
plus sur ces affections de longue durée
et donc qui a dû qui n'a pas remis à
jour les tarifs des soins courants c'est
vrai pour les médecins généralistes
c'est vrai pour les médecins
spécialistes et donc soit on tuait
l'exercice libéral qui ne qu'ils
n'avaient pas le modèle économique parce
que les tarifs étaient insuffisants je
vous prends un exemple y avait 25 euros
de la consultation tout le monde
appréciera si comme prestations
intellectuelles vous enlevez 50% de
charge quand vous allez chez votre
médecin généraliste
les 13 euros que vous lui donnez chacun
peut apprécier si c'est juste une juste
valeur mais vous pouvez prendre les
tarifs chirurgicaux snow quasiment pas
été réévalué depuis 40 ans ou à la marge
savez quand un chirurgien opère une
opération de la hanche
il a le tarif est de 450 euros encore
une fois vous enlevez 50% il a à peu
près 200 euros y'a pas un chirurgien qui
va qui titre qui ne peut vivre faire
tourner un cabinet avec ce type de tarif
tout cas bon donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
dit bah écoutez vous allez avoir une
liberté d'honoraires pour permettre de
compléter alors évidemment avec qui on
peut parler des dérives mais globalement
c'est ce qui a permis de conserver une
toute une population de médecins
libéraux qui représente 50% de la
chirurgie donc de la même façon que de
dire on supprime les mutuelles est
illusoire de la même façon de dire qu'on
supprime le secteur de sans repenser
l'ensemble du système parce que moi je
suis pour la suppression du secteur 2
mais avec une remise à niveau 2 de la
valeur des actes pris par la sécurité
sociale je vous rejoins là dessus moi je
pense qu'il faut que les mutuelles soit
sur des paniers de soins qui soient
dédiés les protestants comme en
allemagne les allemands nous fait les
prothèses dentaires en allemagne vous
avez une part des transports sanitaires
vous avez une part des médicaments à
service médical rendu relativement
faible et est donc au moins il ya une
clarté dans qui fait quoi mais on voit
bien que parce que vous vous êtes des
vrais mutualistes mais on voit bien que
vos collègues qui sont plus des
collègues assurantiel c'est à dire avec
une tarification au risque plutôt qu'une
mutualisation du risque sont vent debout
contre toute transformation d'un système
qui est devenu une honte pour eux ont
des avantages du monopole sans les
inconvénients on fait une pause on y
revient juste après
[Musique]
quel effet le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron aura-t-il eu sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages français on m'a
toujours sous-évalué le rythme de
l'inflation et donc on peut vous chantez
que le pouvoir d'achat a augmenté
la réalité c'est qu'il abaissait le
pouvoir d'achat 8d 0 1% là sur ullrich a
énormément augmenté est ce qu'il faut
pour avoir du pouvoir d'achat partagé
pour la plus grande masse est bien la
seule manière de faire c'est une
activité privée dynamique il permet de
distribuer des revenus suffisants pour
faire face au coût de la vie et la
réalité c'est que sur ce plan rien n'a
été fait vous faites de la dette comme
ça et quand vous imprimer des billets
comme ça vous fléchés de fait sur les
gens qui détiennent le capital
donc ça arrive de fait sur les marchés
par exemple l'action ça fait monter les
titres mais ça ne m'apporte rien dans
votre assiette
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage véritable se situe au niveau des
hommes politiques plus de 3000 ivoiriens
en perdront la vie lors de la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 avec beaucoup
d'attention ça tire de partout c'était
tellement l'as cozes et quand on sortait
envoyait des traces de balles principal
envoyer des trades av en moins d'une
semaine c'était c'était le chaos après
2010 il y avait deux camps celui des
vainqueurs et des vaincus est-ce que la
situation s'est quand même amélioré à ce
niveau le châtel que la victime se
plaignent toujours le fait est que sur
le terrain les divisions existent où
joue le fait est que le climat politique
n'est pas encore véritablement apaisé
[Musique]
quel avenir pour la sécu on reprend
notre débat avec frédéric bizarre qui
est président de l'institut santé avec
jean-jacques vers check et président de
la mutuelle de france unie jean baptiste
noé qui est professeur d'économie
politique à la sorbonne et nicolas da
silva qui est économiste de la santé la
parole est à vous nicolas del ci doit on
parler de la grande fait qu mercereau
j'ai normalement abandonné aujourd'hui
trop difficile à mettre en place aurait
dit olivier veyrat oui bien sûr c'est ce
qu'il dit c'est peu dire que c'est vrai
j'aimerais simplement revenir un instant
en arrière quand on parlait juste avant
la pause 2-2 de la question de la
prévention qui est une question très
importante
s'il s'agit de dire que le système de
santé est tourné vers le curatif et
c'est un problème oui c'est un problème
et il faut penser la transition du
système de santé vers un autre modèle et
notamment en développant des politiques
de prévention des politiques de santé au
travail etc etc ça c'est vrai néanmoins
j insiste sur le fait qu'on ne peut pas
simplement dire qu'il ya un problème de
de gestion et il faudrait simplement
faire mieux en réalité on a vu bien
avant la pandémie notamment en 2019 lors
du grand mouvement social dans l'hôpital
public qui a aussi et tout de suite un
problème de moyens alors évidemment on
pourrait réfléchir à des transformations
dans le temps long sur la façon de
mettre moins nos dépenses de santé dans
l'hôpital notre production public de
santé dans l'hôpital et la mettre plus
en ville cependant on ne peut pas faire
ça à court terme et on veut pas le faire
de façon rapide donc tout de suite ce
qu'on peut faire tout de suite c'est
investir dans les hôpitaux et investir
en moyens et donc ça c'est nécessaire et
il suffit de voir les témoignages des
professionnels de santé qui travaillent
un peu partout il ya d'abord et tout de
suite un problème de moyens bien sûr à
moyen terme et long terme il faut
réfléchir à une réorganisation et à une
amélioration d'articulation ville
hôpital mais ça ça n'est jamais fait
autrement que dans les paroles la grande
victime des politiques de santé c'est
l'hôpital public s'est jamais la
médecine libérale et la médecine de
ville en règle générale d'accor et donc
je pense qu'il faut vraiment insister là
dessus il faut arrêter de dire notamment
aux soignants et aux patients qui nous
écoute que le problème c'est pas le plus
ce le plus de santé le plus de 2,2
d'hôpital c'est le mieux d'hôpital
évidemment on peut toujours faire mieux
et on va le voir avec la grande sécu
mais il faut aussi plus et on a vu à
quel point il y à il ya des problèmes
aujourd'hui en france notamment en
termes d'accès d'accès aux soins et du
coup sûr la grande sécu sauf que la
grande sécu évidemment vous l'avez dit
on sait pas très bien ce qu'il ya
derrière mais de ce qu'on a compris en
fait c'est une réforme
d'efficacité une et forme de justice
sociale pourquoi parce que les
complémentaires santé telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui elles sont chères et
inefficace et pardon injuste elles sont
chères au sens où elle nous coûte plus
cher en termes de frais de gestion que
la sécurité sociale et elles sont
inégalitaires au sens où les gens qui
adhèrent à une mutuelle sont pas tous
les mêmes ils n'ont pas tous les mêmes
remboursements et on arrive à une
situation très paradoxale où les
personnes qui sont le plus en capacité
de payer ont les meilleurs
complémentaires mais ils en ont les
moins besoin et donc ceux qui auraient
plus besoin d'avoir des bonnes
complémentaires ils n'ont pas parce
qu'ils peuvent pas se les payer donc
qu'on aime la rigueur budgétaire ou la
justice sociale étendre la sécu pour en
finir avec ce système à complémentaires
c'est une réforme qu'il faut faire à ces
audiences eux c'était le but de la
grande fait qu un cd l'onu a pris en
charge par l'assurance maladie
obligatoire et peu fiables par les
mutuelles n'ont alors c'était pas tous
et à dambach qu'on n'a pas la partie
qu'est modérateur donc dans le prix
conventionnés il ya une part qui est
prise en charge par la sécurité sociale
et une part qui est ticket modérateur
qui est prise en part par les
complémentaires et ou poêlé au dessus eh
ben c'est le cas par exemple des
dépassements d'honoraires en médecine de
ville et donc cette part au dessus elle
n'était pas sur la table pour l'instant
est ce que ça veut dire que les
dépassements d'honoraires il faut pas
s'en occuper bien sûr que si mais en
tout cas le projet simple d'extension de
la sécurité sociale à cette part qu'on
appelle le ticket modérateur serait une
source d'économie et de justice sociale
qu'on pourrait décider d'utiliser comme
comme on le souhaite peut-être en
réduisant les déficits si on considère
qu'il y en a trop peut-être en
augmentant l'accès aux soins en
investissant dans plus de production de
santé mais en tout cas ça serait une
réforme de bon sens budgétaire pour ceux
qui aiment qui aime beaucoup ses
arguments
notre système de santé est l'un des plus
chers au monde pas parce qu'il est
public parce qu'il est mixte on a des
frais de gestion qui sont proches de
ceux des états unis qui sont à 8 % à 7 %
c'est-à-dire que quand il ya 100 euros
de dépenses de santé il y en a sept qui
sont consacrés à d'âge et à la gestion
de dossiers tandis que par exemple chez
nos voisins britanniques qui ont un
système unique bien imparfait mais
unique les frais de gestion sont moins
2% et donc il faut bien distinguer la
question de l'efficacité de la gestion
de la question du montant des dépenses
et voudrait qu'on s'arrête sur les le
cas des mutuelles mutuelle en général
puisque j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y
avait des bons mutualiste et des mobs
habitués liste que george heck est à
bomber mutualiste d'après freddy bizarre
en ce moment c'est haro sur les
mutuelles elle aurait économisé pendant
le coc vide 2 milliards d'euros et
pourtant s'apprêterait à augmenter leurs
tarifs entre 7 et 10%
tout ça c'est le ministère de la santé
qui les accusent en sentez visé non
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que pendant
le creux vide il ya eu
beaucoup moins de tout a été pris en
charge par nos médias pas que sa fin je
dire plus personne aller chez le
dentiste à la personne
même aller voir son médecin ou
donc il ya eu un ralentissement très
fort comme pour le reste la consommation
voilà
donc ça c'est vrai donc économie d'un
côté il ya une économie sur l'année 2020
ça qui est très claire donc ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que il ya eu des taxes
qui ont été
je crois à hauteur de 2 70% si je dis
pas de bêtises qui ont été prélevées sur
les excédents des mutuelles après de
taxco vie donc voilà il est rare il est
vrai qu'on parle des mutuelles on parle
des mutualistes parce que derrière c'est
quand même le mutualiste qui paye va je
dire après il faut savoir aussi que en
gros
il ya entre 15 % pour les contrats
responsables et 20 % pour les contrats
non responsables et j'attire votre
attention les contrats non responsables
c'est les gens les plus modestes qui
n'ont pas pu accéder au contraire
responsable qu'on a laissé dans des
contrats non responsables c'est à dire
qu'ils sont remboursés moins que les
autres - avec les autres et ces gens là
on les taxe à 20 % c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui la mutualité elle est plus
taxé que mcdonald's qui si vous prenez
un hamburger à emporter qui est mauvais
pour la santé en plus on a 5 50 donc là
dessus après quand parle des frais de
gestion des mutuelles moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord puisque nous on est pour
une sécurité crs 100% mais il faut pas
non plus dire que les mutualistes sont
de mauvais gestionnaires parce que
l'assiette de cotisations des mutuelles
en moyenne ces 1000 euros l'assiette
d'une cotisation de la sécu c'est 7000
euros donc comment comment expliquez
vous alors que lens est l'augmentation
des tarifs match par écrit pour 2022
alors il ya une augmentation des tarifs
sur 2021 qui est très claire elle est
due au rattrapage de soins sur 2020 où
les gens sont pas les chèvres il salue
donc c'est habituel bah ça on a une
augmentation des dépenses de santé
importantes
sur l'exercice 2021 et la mutuelle
que je préside sera à peine à
l'équilibré sur l'année 2000 21 due à
l'augmentation des dépenses de santé
puisqu'on a aussi
sur l'année sur l'exercice au 1er
janvier 2021 on a volontairement très
peu augmenté nos cotisations puisqu'on a
augmenté à peu près d'un pour cent en
moyenne avec blizzard a roulé sur les
mutuelles non mais enfin ça c'est pas
parce que j'ai sorti il ya quelques
années un livre s'appelle
complémentaires santé le scandale qui
bouge et un petit peu détricoter le
système et la cour des comptes a repris
80% de mes arguments il ya six mois donc
je crois que le conseil doit être
partagée d'accord il n'est pas
évidemment partagé par le monde
assurantiel qui évidemment il trouve son
compte mais il est partagé partage en
grande partie ce qui a été dit là c'est
un système qui est inefficace sinon avec
une telle couverture
assurantielle avec aussi peu de restes à
charge globale le monde serait
merveilleux et il n'est pas merveilleux
donc il ya bien un problème dans l'
architecture de ce financement la bon et
on est on quand on connaît un peu le
système on sait bien que ce système à
deux étages doit être doit être changé
il ya un système organisationnel ou vous
avez des contrats collectifs et des
contrats individuels comme ça a été dit
ceux qui ont le plus besoin d'être
protégés sont le moins bien protégée
parce qu'il paye 100 % de leurs primes
et donc ils ont des contrats de mauvaise
qualité est là où le monde assurantielle
doit se méfier c'est pour ça que le
politique commence à sentir qu'il faut
s'intéresser à ce système là parce qu'on
va vers un système kiva s'américaniser
où vous allez avoir des gens qui vont
sortir du système assurantiel privé
qu'on a rendu indispensables pour
certains soins comme les prothèses
dentaires comme notamment les accès à
certains spécialistes mais dont une
partie de la classe moyenne va être
exclue parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez ce
qu'on appelle le taux d'effort c'est à
dire la part du revenu qui est dédié à
payer les complémentaires santé qui
devient prohibitif qui est souvent de
l'ordre de 10% pour la classe moyenne
la classe moyenne vous avez aujourd'hui
un mois un mois et demi de revenus d'un
couple de salades de retraités qui tique
est dédié à ce financement là avec un
retour sur ce financement en termes
d'accès aux soins qui est absolument
insuffisant donc évidemment les gens
vont sortir de ce système là et donc sur
un plan politique ça pose un problème et
c'est pour ça que et que les
le gouvernement sent bien que de toute
façon il faut sauf qu'encore une fois il
faut savoir que le système de
financement c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
structurant en angleterre vous avez la
santé gratuite quand j'entends je crois
percevoir que vous vous êtes pour une
santé 100% remboursé mais c'est plus un
modèle à la française vous allez vers un
modèle à l'anglais à ce moment là vous
vous dédié à l'état payé en grande
partie par la peau mais à la limite peu
importe le rôle d'opérateur et vous avez
un système à deux vitesses qui est
assumée vous avez un filet de sécurité
qui est fait que ont fait le mieux
possible avec l'argent qu'on a pour le
peuple et ceux qui veulent un système
plus performant qualitatif vont dans le
privé qui n'est plus mixte avec le
système public qui est à la marge du
système avec un financement privé un
système à l'anglais moi je crois
pourquoi pas mais je ne crois pas que ça
soit adaptée à la à la culture française
qui est épris d'égalité de liberté vous
n'avez aussi plus divers que des morts
et professionnels de santé le système à
deux vitesses c'est aujourd'hui en
france dsk il se dégrade il
faudrait de vitesse que j'avais vu qu'il
n'était pas structuré leur vitesse il
est peut-être déjà enfin ça c'est mon
avis n'est pas ce qui c'est la réalité
des grappes parce que monsieur parce
qu'ils se dégradent d'accord donc c'est
bien pour ça qu'il faut le repenser mais
comment est-ce qu'on le repenser est-ce
qu'on va vers un système encore une fois
à l anglaise à l'américaine où elles
seront ré invente un modèle à la
française et dans le modèle à la
française vous n'avez pas la santé
gratuite vous avez une participation
financière aux soins courants qu'on
appelle le ticket modérateur qui est
absolument structurants dans le système
donc et c'est pour ça qu'avec 78% de
niveaux de prise en charge par
l'assurance maladie le problème n'est
pas cette année ce montant global de
prise en charge idée plutôt supérieur à
la majorité des pays mais là c'est à une
discussion entre ceux qui veulent aller
encore une fois vers un rebond soit 1,60
mais il faut aller au bout de la logique
vous n'avez plus de berthet de choix de
votre professionnel de santé et vous
avez un système de files d'attentes 1
lorsque vous avez une santé gratuite la
maîtrise des dépenses ou sinon vous
dirai comment vous faites c'est par les
files d'attentes et ça marche
remarquablement bien en angleterre c'est
9 % contre 11 % de nous depuis sauf que
vous avez 6 millions d'anglais qui
attendent d'eux des consultations
prévues ou des opérations prévues et je
pense que ça socialement en france n'est
pas tenable c'est une gestion de la
pénurie et c'est un des problèmes comme
mais focaliser sur les coûts et sur les
déficits on est dans une gestion de
uniquement de maintenir le mais mieux
possible le trou de la sécu ou le budget
du déficit de la sécu est donc l'une des
raisons parler pour une des raisons
c'est pas la seule cause mais de la
manque de médecins aujourd'hui de
praticiens de la santé parce qu'on a
réduit le nombre de médecins ils ont
même moyen aura moins environ huit mois
ils auront se faire soigner donc moins
il y aura de dépenses en
1995 ou 16 où on a engagé des médecins à
partir à la santé à la retraite parfois
de façon anticipée en disant pas comme
ça on a trop de médecins donc on aura
moins et donc on aura moins de dépenses
est aujourd'hui au contraire on a des
déserts médicaux y compris d'ailleurs
dans les villes et dans les grandes
métropoles et un autre une autre
conséquence aussi on l'a vu c'était la
critique où il a été un révélateur en
fait des systèmes qui fonctionnait bien
ou moins bien qui est sur le
plafonnement des prix du médicament
puisque les industries de la santé oms
des coûts de production d'un médicament
ont des coûts de recherche d'innovation
et donc il faut ensuite payer ses coûts
par la vente du médicament or comme le
budget de bleu le budget de la sécu et
et focaliser uniquement sur les coûts il
fixe le prix du médicament non pas en
fonction de ce que ça coûte à produire
mais en fonction de ce que ça va limiter
en matière de dépenses et une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a vu partir
des années 2015 et ça s'est accéléré
début des années 2020
2019 2020 une délocalisation des usines
de production de médicaments c'était en
réalité pour faire baisser les coûts de
production de manière à pouvoir limiter
la baisse du prix des médicaments alors
après on s'en est plaint en dix ans on a
perdu à savoir faire industriel on a
perdu une partie de la chaîne de
production ce qui est vrai
mais il faut bien se rendre compte que
le budget de la sécu étant focalisé
uniquement sur la limitation du prix on
est en train de détruire cette industrie
du médicament dont on s'est rendu compte
qu'elle est extrêmement importante et
elle est en plus sales extrêmement
complexe parce qu'on voit souvent les
grands rôles et les fal et les
entreprises phares comme sanofi ou
d'autres il ya tout un réseau de pme qui
vivent aussi de ça et donc quand on
pense à la santé il faut penser aux les
infirmières les médecins généralistes
les spécialistes mais aussi toute cette
industrie de fabrication des prothèses
des bases de médicaments de l'ensemble
de même des des permet de prendre deux
flacons qui permet de tenir le vaccin et
ça c'est tout un écosystème qui est de
plus en plus bringuebalant par le fait
qu' on a larchitecture qui est en train
de s'effriter nicolas tu décides bah
je vais le redire excusez moi de me
répéter beaucoup de mon point de vue la
sécurité sociale est en pleine santé
financière et à mon avis il faut séparer
les sujets le sujet de la grande sécu
c'est un sujet pour savoir est ce que
oui ou non on peut faire des économies
à budget constant
la réponse qu'on aurait tendance à dire
c'est que non seulement on peut faire
des économies
ces frais de gestion dont on peut
discuter l'étendue qui sont
effectivement supérieure à des systèmes
de santé
comparables dans le monde donc ça c'est
lui le la question la grande sait qu ils
sont très très de gestion sont très
importants quand on regarde les frais de
gestion des institutions de la santé en
france vous avez 7 milliards d'euros qui
sont dépensés par la sécurité sociale
d'un côté et 7 milliards d'euros par les
par les complémentaires de l'autre or
d'un côté vous avez la sécurité sociale
qui rembourse 75 % des dépenses quand
les complémentaires en bourse à peine 15
donc évidemment et encore une fois ça a
été dit il un constat qui est de plus en
plus largement partagée et par des
institutions aussi respectable que la
cour des comptes par exemple le hkm au
conseil l'avenir de l'assurance maladie
l'efsc la plupart des économistes
reconnaissent et donc
sescousse et des surcoûts et donc ça
c'est la question de la gestion sur les
questions de la gestion à budget
constant il ya 7 milliards d'économies
on a fait une réforme de l'isf pour
moins que ça ensuite il ya la question
du niveau des dépenses et de la
régulation de
l'offre là aussi entièrement d'accord il
faut repenser la question des
dépassements d'honoraires il faut
repenser la question des relations entre
la sécurité sociale et les producteurs
quels qu'ils soient
hôpitaux médecins infirmiers etc etc et
enfin dernière question et je voudrais
aussi répondre là dessus c'est la
question politique qui décide alors là
je dois dire je suis radicalement opposé
au fait et je que ce soit le ministre et
le ministère qui décide de comment on
organise la sécurité sociale parce que
ça effectivement c'est un système à la
britannique c'est à dire un système
nationalisée est attisée
mais encore une fois c'est pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le sujet la
grande sécu ça reste est attisée parce
que l'étatisation c'est aujourd'hui
c'est comme la médecine à deux vitesses
c'est aujourd'hui les déserts médicaux
c'est aujourd'hui tout ça c'est
aujourd'hui c'est pas des menaces c'est
la réalité aujourd'hui donc c'est pas le
sujet de la grande circulation au sujet
d'avon cqcd économies restent toutes ces
questions qui sont posées et notamment
celle de la de la gestion politique de
la sécurité sociale est là pour le coup
je pense qu'il faut retourner vers la
grande originalité de 45 et te dire que
les plus fins connaisseurs de deux des
besoins de santé c'est les gens
eux-mêmes et donc rebasculer un système
de démocratie sociale avec des élections
pour discuter et décider politiquement
de ce que l'on rembourse et de ce que
l'on rembourse pas et probablement que
ainsi on décidera de rembourser
différemment l'industrie pharmaceutique
qui effectivement est une économie de
rente peut-être qu'on décida on décidera
de rembourser différemment les médecins
qui pratiquent des dépassements
d'honoraires et donc c'est vraiment
cette question politique c'est une autre
question qui crucial peut-être même plus
importante mais c'est une autre question
que celle simplement de l'économie qu'on
pourrait réaliser sur la question des
complémentaires santé joseph verschelle
alors moi je la partage
après tout ce que vous dîtes surtout sur
la gestion de notre système de santé je
pense qu'il faut qu'on revienne à 1945
ou c'étaient les syndicats qui
représentait les salariés et les
retraités qui gérait le système là on
est en train d'être attisé et je crois
qu'il faut vraiment que la sécurité
sociale universelle soit gérée par les
représentants des salariés
puisque c'est eux qui seront plus près
du terrain pour faire remonter j'irai
les besoins de la population et puis par
rapport à l'industrie pharmaceutique
je vous invite à lire un petit bouquin
de médecins du monde
qui définit comme est fixé le prix d'un
médicament par les grands laboratoires
qui sort de nouveaux traitements contre
le cancer ou des choses comme ça et en
fait il est fixé en fonction des
possibilités financières de chaque état
et il est fixé pas pour que tout le
monde se soigner ils ont des algorithmes
qui leur permet d'établir qui a
peut-être 20 30% de la population qui
sera pas soigné mais que notre sécurité
sociale est prêt à acheter de
médicaments at elle pris et sectorielles
un bouquin qui est très édifiant
parce qu'avant je veux dire c'était de
manière assez classique on mettait les
frais de recherche de fabrication de
publicité le bénéfice que faisait
l'entreprise et le prix du médicament
était fixé comme ça et maintenant il est
fixé de manière beaucoup plus perverse
ou quand on voit un médicament un état
on sait que en tout cas dans un premier
temps l'ensemble de la population ne
pourra pas bénéficier de ce traitement
et je crois que là on atteint cynisme
relativement absolu de la part de
l'industrie pharmaceutique qui je le
rappelle est quand même la deuxième
industrie la plus rentable dans le monde
après l'industrie de l'armement se veut
discret oui frésard et jean baptiste ne
suis pas
le médicament enfin vous avez
c'est bon c'est pas que les traitements
et
fabricants de directive en les
traitements anti contre le cancer le
diabète qui sont extrêmement coûteux et
mais vous avez même toit tous les
produits de base est ce qu'on oublie
aussi que la médecine vétérinaire
parce que les deux sont liés médecine
vétérinaire et médecine animale et il ya
de plus en plus justement à la recherche
mais médical des interactions qui sont
réalisés entre les deux parce que des
maladies qui vont passer de la volaille
à l'être humain donc on est vraiment
dans une logique globale et les
industries du médicament aujourd'hui
travaillent de plus en plus fort c'est
l'interaction là et aussi sur l'accès au
real à la médecine quasiment
quotidiennes classique pour des maladies
moins importante ou moins onéreuse à
soigner mais qui sont qu'il faut traiter
lorsque les gens les maisons
risquaient alors comme là on est entre
personnes qui connaissent qui
connaissons le système de santé on est à
peu près d'accord sur le constat qu une
fois il ya un diagnostic qui est là bon
mais là l'occasion c'est comment est ce
qu'on fait comment est-ce qu'on
redynamise la recherche médicale comment
est-ce qu'on rembourse mieux et on fixe
de façon plus plus juste les innovations
thérapeutiques comment est-ce qu'on
réinvente la démocratie sociale et
sanitaire monsieur a parfaitement raison
je veux dire si on veut réinventer un
modèle à la française il faut qu'on ait
un état qui soit fort là où doit être
fort c'est-à-dire un définition d'une
stratégie dans la définition d'une
vision maintenant dans la définition
d'un budget qui est votée au parlement
nous nous proposons pas pour ça qu'on
crée l'institut santé a connu ça parce
qu'il faut trouver un consensus 1 les
yaka fokon c'est désastreux il n'y a
plus c'est bien mais on est là pour
apporter des solutions concrètes et si
possible qu'on sensuelle il n'y a pas de
politique de gauche politique de droite
pour reconstruire un système de santé
s'il ya eu cette alliance gaullistes et
communistes en 1945 c'est pas points il
faut la retrouver quelque part en contre
avec la cgt entre avec des libéraux
entrent avec tout le monde et par
exemple vous faites une loi de
programmation sanitaires à 5 ans comme
ya une loi de programmation militaire
vous permettait à l'état d'avoir un une
perspective et un cadre comment est-ce
qu'on redéfinisse cette démocratie
sociale et sanitaire c'est pas simple ce
que je pense et qui on a créé les outils
on est par exemple une conférence
nationale de santé qui regroupe
l'ensemble des acteurs du système adam
six groupes qui sont mais dont tout le
monde se fout puisque on ne va pas
donner de fonction nous avons des comics
et régionaux des conseils régionaux de
sanitaires et d'autonomie qui regroupe
l'ensemble des acteurs d'une région et
qui font un travail remarquable mais qui
sont consultatifs 1 c'est tout le
pouvoir est dans les mains de l'état à
travers des agences régionales de santé
nous ce que nous proposons c'est que par
exemple cette conférence nationale
devienne le conseil d'administration de
l'union nationale des caisses
d'assurance maladie c'est à dire que
vous ayez les représentants des acteurs
qui est un vrai rôle il ya peut-être de
meilleures idées faut les mettre sur la
table et donc voilà à l'échelle
régionale il faut il faut redonner il
faut à nouveau donner une autonomie aux
unions régionales des caisses
d'assurance maladie qu'on était absorbé
dans les agences étatiques en fait
l'assurance maladie a d'ailleurs c'était
intéressant d'écouter le ministre ce
week-end il remerciait tous les acteurs
sauf l'assurance maladie en fait quand
l'état parle il considère que
l'assurance maladie c'est lui la star
aux maladies et donc en fait on au musée
vous a écouté ça vous souvent les
ministres-présidents on parle jamais de
l'assurance maladie puis qui considère
que c'est lui qui est donc moi je suis
d'accord avec ce mouvement il faut faire
mais il faut le faire concrètement donc
il faut redonner une vraie autonomie à
l'union à l'assurance pas dit moi je
pense qu'il faut aussi unifier il faut
une gouvernance des soins parce qu'on a
les l'hôpital qui est dirigé par l'état
les professionnels de villes qui sont
dirigés par l'assurance maladie et puis
le médico-social qui entre une caisse
nationale santé autonomie qui est
largement alimentée par les deniers
d'assurance maladie et puis elle
département bref il faut re clarifier la
gouvernance la gouvernance j'aime pas
trop simplifié à outrance et c'est quand
même la mère des réformes une fois qu'on
a remis sur pied une gouvernance qui
permet à l'état d'avoir le rôle qui doit
avoir à une démocratie sociale et
sanitaire piloté par l'assurance maladie
ce que vous avez quand même remis
sérieusement de la clarté dans le
système commentaire autre solution
envisagée
que des styles va non rapidement parce
qu'il nous reste une monsieur richard
rapidement ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que sur la question simple qui est celle
de la grande sécu c'est à dire une
réforme qui est assez simple beaucoup
beaucoup plus simple que repolitiser re
démocratiser la sécurité sociale même si
ce coup ci c'est ce qu'il conviendrait
faire sur cette réforme 5 on peut voir à
quel point finalement notre système de
santé est un système rentier pourquoi
parce que en fait on a un système de
santé qui est publique mais qui est
parasité par des intérêts qui sont les
intérêts de des complémentaires santé
qui pour le coup sont pas suffisamment
efficaces et qui sont comment dire
inégalitaire parasité par
l'industrie pharmaceutique
parasitée par
les médecins libéraux en tout cas la
frange la plus libérale et la plus
combative d'un point de vue politique et
donc on a un système qui est publique
mais sur lequel on n'a pas la main parce
qu'il ya tout tout ces rentes qui
rendent impossible
la prise de décisions citoyenne outre
niveau de parasitage c'est le la
bureaucratisation qui est réelle et que
c'est un vrai problème la
bureaucratisation c'est le sait le sait
le négatif photographique de l'absence
de démocratie on a créé plein d' agences
de santé avec des gens dedans qui sont
probablement très compétent experts je
pourrais en être donc je me mets dedans
et ce sont ces gens là qui décide au nom
de tous les autres et donc c'est pour ça
que moi ce que j'invite à penser c'est
justement comment est ce qu'on fait pour
démocratiser le système de santé et
j'invite les gens qui nous écoutent à
lire et à se renseigner parce que
la situation paraît évidente il y à des
dépenses qui sont extravagantes dans des
choses qui devraient pas être dépensés
et pourtant on continue pourquoi parce
que l'enjeu est d'abord politique plus
qu'économique je remercie tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oui
m